hey mateo thanks for doing this and and
congrats on the fundraise uh that's
awesome i am personally obviously a big
believer in eight sleep uh i tell the
story often that when i moved down from
new york city to miami it was one of the
only things that i actually brought in
the car with me uh just because i knew
that i wanted it the second i got there
so uh big believer in your guys product
my question though would be around uh
for people that are getting started and
starting to look at their sleep more uh
and how they can make improvements on it
and get better sleep and deeper sleep
and rest better what are just like is is
adjusting the temperature and
controlling that the first step or are
there other things that they should look
at and kind of how do you think about
improving your sleep from like step one
to five
yeah great question so obviously
temperature is the big elephant in the
room if you want to improve your sleep
you need temperature so the best way is
to deposit because the temperature of
the bed that changes and so it's in
direct contact with your body second
step is the temperature of your bedroom
so try to set a temperature somewhere
between 68 and 72 degrees based on your
preference the issue you will have with
that is your partner might not like the
same temperature and so that is a
problem we solved then there are a
couple of other acts that
i leverage so one is what i call thermal
shock so an hour before going to bed try
to take a hot and cold shower so you do
30 seconds hot and 30 seconds as cold as
possible that thermal shock will help
you to relax
then i use a product called the normatec
boots are these boots that you can put
on your legs and they will compress your
legs so they will help with circulation
and recovery in particular if you train
during the day
i use smart lighting so lights they have
a major impact on your melatonin levels
and so what happens in my house the
lights start changing around 7 30 they
switch to orange and then they keep
dimming down every 30 minutes and by 9
30 they are completely off
i do some mobility exercises you can do
some sort of stretching and flexibility
uh just to lose up before going to bed
the other big factors are really alcohol
in my case i stopped drinking alcohol
almost three years ago and that was one
of the biggest factors because sometimes
now you drink and you know you feel uh
you feel like okay now i could go to
sleep but the reality is that alcohol
will have an impact on your hrv and hr
and so you should at least stop drinking
alcohol a couple of hours before going
to bed
and then the other one is is caffeine
you should stop drinking caffeine eight
to ten hours before going to bed
john
yeah hey mateo nice to see you again all
right john what are you doing
i'm doing great um so i'm curious a
couple people have asked in the chat
what is your sleep schedule and how has
it changed over the last few years have
you built up eight sleep
yeah
at the beginning i was not
obsessed with sleep well instead now of
the am
and i'm seeing a lot of benefits in that
so i tend to sleep somewhere between
eight and nine hours
i tend to go to sleep around 10
um and then i wake up early uh i do all
the things i just described before going
to bed and then in the morning i have
another routine that i call like priming
so it's what really gives me energy and
so i try to do exercise for 30 minutes i
try to do an ice bath or a very cold
shower and then i try to
think about gratitude so a couple of
things i should be happy about in my
life and and 10 minutes off just i call
it i call it monkey time when i do
nothing i just look outside and and i
try to you know let my brain rest
nice
mateo when you think about um kind of
the average person some of the things
that you're talking about uh take quite
a bit of time is there one thing that
you're like this is the secret uh or
this is the most impactful thing they
could do is it temperature is it light
is it the thermoshock
you know how do you kind of take
somebody who's got a really busy
schedule they're like hey man i can't do
everything this sounds awesome like tell
me the one thing or tell me the the
easiest things to do which ones do you
point them to
yeah it's a good question i would start
so the first thing is you need to put
the time and sleep enough right that is
number one rule if you sleep five hours
whatever i suggest will not work so that
is why we call it sleep fitness right
the same way you put the time and the
effort to go to the gym and train three
four five times a week you should do the
same with your sleep it's like going to
the gym you're doing something very
valuable for your body
then outside you know that so sleeping
seven to nine hours i would say
temperature is number one
alcohol is number two and caffeine is
number three
what do you do with caffeine i know that
you drink some caffeine uh for those
that don't know mateo is italian and uh
he drinks uh not american coffee uh so
maybe tell us what caffeine do you drink
and then explain um the the kind of
cadence of drinking coffee and then when
you stop to make sure that you actually
get some sleep
yeah so you should stop drinking coffee
somewhere between eight ten ten hours
before going to bed uh so that is the
the rule of thumb so in my case around 1
or 2 p.m at the latest i stopped
drinking and usually if i have a coffee
at the time it's decaf so decaf keep in
mind still have caffeine it's just
usually a third of what a regular coffee
has in my case i drink all the espressos
so i have just a couple of espressos um
in a day
which is probably less than the caffeine
of this less caffeine than a typical
american cup of coffee
the other thing is super interesting and
i started doing a few times because i
don't have a lot of time but sometimes i
nap
and when i nap i drink an espresso right
before going to bed
and so it will take around 30 minutes
for the espresso for the coffee to kick
in so by the time you wake up from the
nap if you just do a 20-30 minute snap
you will feel refreshed because
adenosine is lower because of the nap
plus the coffee just kicked in and so
you feel like superman
wait a minute
hold on i've never heard this before
you
drink an espresso and then you turn
around and you take a nap immediately
for 30 minutes and when you wake up you
feel like superman because the nap
plucks the espresso 30 minutes later
ends up being like rocket fuel for your
day
correct
that is it's called nappucino i think
there is something like a term to
describe anything
and it works like awesome man
i i mean i just respect the fact that
you figured that out is that like a
known thing
yeah yeah yeah if you google it you find
it so i'm not the only human being there
are a few human beings doing it and i'm
one of them but i'm not the only one
that is incredible hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
gonna build the biggest business show in
the world and we need your help
[Music]